[Musica]
zanichelli alla voce disordine nel punto
4 dice tumulto moto popolare
ecco questa è in questa definizione ci
sono molti concetti che sono anche
inclusi nel mondo della vita della
cucina se ci fermiamo a riflettere
infatti riusciamo a vedere in tumulto
l'idea di un movimento peristaltica come
una contrazione muscolare
un suono vibrante che genera una scossa
una vibrazione e un'emozione di uno
spostamento da uno stato iniziale a uno
stato finale nuovo grazie al tool molto
nella parola molto popolare invece vedo
un idea di fluidità di spostamento
liquido ma compatto collettivo verso una
direzione ignota e non definita l'anima
della cucina può racchiudere può essere
racchiusa in queste due parole la cucina
un tumulto perché nasce dalla fame e lì
che inizia e finisce ed è in moto
popolare perché come la lingua che
parliamo in continua trasformazione
segue le persone le loro passioni le
loro paure
segue quello la loro aggressività e la
loro dolcezza è da sempre una natura
collettiva
per quanto mi riguarda è quello di più
vicino che ci possa essere al jazz e al
blues due generi che sono nati dalle
pulsioni vere e dai ritmi dai desideri
primordiali da quello che è veramente
folk inteso come viscerale e popolare
nel video che avete visto si collega il
mio concetto di disordine questo e fa
vedere tutti i nostri ragazzi
io ho 21 anni e questi sono tutti
ragazzi che lavorano con me nel nostro
ristorante è un ristorante stupendo io
ho la fortuna e il peso di essere su
chef essere parte di un team e in un
senso lato di nella generazione che alla
convinzione di poter riscrivere le
regole della gastronomia mondiale questo
è quello che crediamo di fare abbiamo la
presunzione di il sogno di essere quel
modo che segnerà un nuovo passaggio
culturale ed epocale per cui per me oggi
disordine
cio vuol dire principalmente a scoprire
piatto dopo piatto una nuova cultura
quotidiana più sana e pensa al disordine
alimentare più sostenibile per l'essere
umano e per il pianeta più saporita
perché il sapore genera felicità più
canzo più consapevole e tollerante il
cibo il primo mezzo che ci racconta che
dalla fusione dei popoli che nasce il
bello
l'italia per me è uno dei paesi più
belli del mondo e lo penso veramente
abbiamo avuto uno spigoli e di cultura è
pazzesco pensata l'utilizzo delle spezie
in sicilia da noi in puglia ai pomodori
che a napoli hanno stato il primo
utilizzo in cucina
a differenza del dell'antichità in cui
venivano utilizzati semplicemente come
piante ornamentali o addirittura
ritenute piante povere dei francesi a
milano lo zafferano
tutte queste vicende nascono dal
disordine e questo disordine me lo
ritrovo tutto in cucina sotto forma di
ingredienti a questi diamo sempre un
nuovo significato diverso dal precedente
in grado di suscitare delle nuove
emozioni se pensiamo alla biodiversità
gastronomica in italia il lavoro dello
chef come quel lavoro di che fare un
designer tra tutti questi bisogna
riuscire a scegliere le varietà che ci
sono paesi in più di un pomodoro per il
gusto perciò per l'acidità per la
consistenza e anche per la modalità
dell'utilizzo perciò il taglio alla
cottura e questo verrà accompagnato ad
altri ingredienti altri credenti che
possono essere di diverse di diverse
fatture diverse consistenze e che
insieme daranno un miscuglio di sapore
acido sapido dolce e noi quello che
facciamo e lavorare sul background
gustativo il nostro background gustativo
quello salentino e lavoriamo appunto su
questi sapori portiamo al passato con
sapori come il liquame quello dei romani
quello che ci dà il rancido lum amico
e pensiamo a quello presente con la
ricotta forte è un nostro piatto forte e
questo sapore rancido e al futuro al
futuro con le palle di ficodindia questa
nostra ricerca e lavora sul sapore più
che sulla ingrediente arriva dopo questa
è una manifestazione e di un gusto
primitivo e della memoria la
fermentazione quindi diventa uno
strumento di continuità per condensare
il gusto quindi del rancido che un
sapore acido e da lì bilanciare il
piatto con altri sapori che possono
essere quello del dolce quello del
salato quello del fermentato questo è
quello che facciamo noi per esempio con
il nostro piatto e che pomodorini fiori
e ricotta forte i pomodorini dolci acidi
un miscuglio di pepi che vengono tutto
il mondo con diverse diversi sapori
diversi profumi e la nostra ricotta
forte perciò la nostra salentinità una
delle cose più interessanti della
cultura europea e principalmente di
quella italiana e francese e proprio che
noi abbiamo un concetto di sazietà e di
pienezza che sono due cose separate
essere sazio in primis e e un attimo
prima di e dell'essere pieno per quello
che diciamo noi nel salento e che lo
troppo stroppia e in italiano sarebbe il
troppo stroppia
ecco questa parola e per indicare il
liquido perfetto per il concetto della
sazietà che implica una pienezza gioiosa
ma serena che non da pesantezza mentre
la pesa la pienezza impiega un abusano
le condizioni di disordine di
affaticamento
questi sono tutti valori che entrano
nella realizzazione di un piatto e della
costruzione dei nostri menu il suo
ordine nel rapporto con il nostro corpo
questo non è un qualcosa che facciamo
soltanto per passione ma da questo
dipende soprattutto la nostra
sopravvivenza perché non dimentichiamo
che
per un utente andare a mangiare fuori e
un gusto è un capriccio un desiderio ma
per uno chef ricevere quel gusto quel
capriccio è quel desiderio la
sopravvivenza perché senza quel
desiderio non possiamo vivere quindi il
primo tumulto il primo disordine nasce
proprio dall equilibrio necessario che
si che si deve instaurare tra noi e il
cliente perché nonostante io cucino in
un ristorante d'italia ed alta cucina la
cucina non 3 non deve mai tradire la sua
vera esistente la sua vera essenza la
sua resistenza per quello noi
impiantiamo la nostra vita dal petto di
una quaglia che è soltanto lungo sette
centimetri ma da quel pezzo di quaglia
dipende il nostro lavoro da ogni
centimetro che andranno a mangiare il
gusto
il sapore e deve arrivare attraverso la
lingua attraverso i sensi da quella
quaglia inizia inizia la nostra il
nostro lavoro inizia a sentirsi e la
l'intensità del lavoro e che c'è dietro
l'umidità lo stato d'animo e lo stesso
ingrediente è sempre in cambiamento è
sempre diverso perciò e anche lì che è
la nostra difficoltà nel lavorarlo e nel
mantenere sempre il nostro equilibrio
beh il disordine è sempre dietro
l'angolo
nelle quantità delle proporzioni nel
relativismo del palato individuale
perché alla fine ognuno di noi ha un
palato diverso è difficile per noi anche
poter soddisfarli tutti però è un lavoro
che cerchiamo di fare è proprio qui che
sta la nostra procura
perciò noi cerchiamo di dare il nostro
ma cerchiamo di dare il più possibile e
cercare di dare la giusta melodia ai
nostri piatti e cercare di farla
comprendere perciò cercare di soddisfare
e anche in maniere diverse tutti i
vostri palati
ovviamente quello che speriamo è che non
suoni come una musica disordinata
questa è la mia vita questo è quello che
ho cercato di riportarvi in questi pochi
minuti e trascorro circa 14 ore della
mia giornata nel ristorante insieme ai
miei colleghi ho 21 anni e tra una
portata el'altra mi dice mi concede un
po di riposo nel silenzio con da
floriano i miei cani in questo silenzio
però penso penso sempre a a due a due
motti a due frasi che mi fanno capire
quanto sia irregolare la nostra vita
ancora non mi sono dato una risposta dir
il vero e spero che voi mi riesce a dare
un nesso a queste le frasi sono queste
ci vogliono tre generazioni per creare
uno psicotico
questo lo dice maria gauguin mentre in
giappone
mi dicevano che ci vogliono tre
generazioni per creare un palato gourmet
[Applauso]
[Musica]